depuis la chute de Liman les Ukrainiens
continuent d'avancer continue cette
contre-offensive à la fois sur le front
est mais également sur le front sud et
ce qui est frappant c'est vraiment la
vitesse à laquelle il progresse depuis
le début de cette grande
contre-offensive à l'est de lancer au
début du mois de septembre et bien
chaque jour les troupes du crayon
regagnent du territoire un commandant
sur le front est nous disait l'objectif
c'est d'arriver à avancer très
rapidement à avancer par petit groupe
pour ne pas laisser aux troupeux c'est
bien le temps de construire des lignes
de défense le temps de se réorganiser et
c'est vrai qu'on voit et bien des
soldats russes qui ont le plus grand mal
à contenir cette contre-offensive des
soldats russes qui le plus souvent
battent en retraite alors sur le front
sud également là où il y a beaucoup plus
de trancher beaucoup plus de
fortifications notamment dans la région
de Carson là aussi les Ukrainiens ont
réussi une percée ces derniers jours qui
continuent une percer de plusieurs de
plusieurs de plusieurs kilomètres au
moins
kilomètres donc c'est vrai qu'on voit
vraiment ces troubles ukrainiennes qui
continuent à progresser qui
méthodiquement s'attaque et bien aux
communication des troupes russes mais
également à leur voie de ravitaillement
et aux neuf ferroviaires pour ne pas et
bien leur laisser l'opportunité de se
ravitailler que ce soit en homme et en
munitions par ailleurs ce qu'il faut
noter également quand vous discutez avec
les commandants Ukrainiens c'est qu'ils
ont conscience que ces succès tactiques
qu'ils enregistrent et bien ont aussi
des effets politiques puisque il faut
noter et bien que ces avancées se font
notamment dans deux régions le Dombas et
la région de Carson région annexée la
semaine dernière par la Russie
dans